um you hate a liar
yes i do okay so you hate liars but now
we're going to play a game with nikki
bens called two truths and a lie
okay
so we've done our research nikki benz
you're very googleable
and we've seen you do some interviews
i'm going to let our panel here also
guess we're going to let the audience
also guess i'm going to tell two truths
and a lie and they're going to have to
decipher which one is the lie you ready
to play this game yes and i i stay quiet
right you stay quiet do not reveal
don't say that's the lie
because that's the [ __ ] whole game
baby okay baby okay
boom we're already on baby baby level
this is how it happens oh my god all
right alex it's okay to smile by the way
you can have fun today russians don't
smile
[Laughter]
this is the most happy i've ever been
it's the culture
uh it's okay all right two truths and a
lie with nikki benz nikki benz once made
out with the famous singer the weeknd
and said he's the best kisser
ever hmm is that a truth or a lie
let's go that's number two
um
nikki benz had sex with justin bieber
and revealed that he's packing
okay biebs
and the number three nikki benz actually
prefers just a regular
sized johnson nothing special those are
the three stories did she make out with
the weekend and says that he's the best
kisser ever did she bang the biebs and
say that homie is packing and is nikki
ben just looking for an average sized
johnson out there in the wild which one
is it let's get our let's get the chat
to guess which one is the lie
and which two are the truth obviously
would you guys like to go nikki do not
reveal let's see what our guest panel
has to say what the lie is and um
then we'll go on to our
valuetaining audience out there
who would like to go first i'll go first
i think i think it's the first one
the first one is the lie yeah okay so
you think that she did not make out with
the weekend you think that she did bang
the biebs and then she's looking for
just a regular size johnson yes okay is
that your final answer sir final answer
okay amber joy lane
what do you think what is nikki lying
about which was the lie right there i
also wanted to say one just based off of
the
the reactions yeah that's what i was
going on
yeah that was the reaction you would
also say so you don't know you're a good
actress you don't think she made out
with the weekend
no
oh who's here and tonight or this
weekend hey
so you think that get us tickets
she's got his contact information but i
can tell natalia
are you um
you're looking for our um
are people responding over there i just
put the poll up okay but what are the
comments saying comments are saying what
do they think the last time i said two
was
two is a lie
threes
but they all say two is a lie i'm seeing
two is the lie one and three are true
and natalia do you know the answer um i
which one is a lie yes i think
justin bieber is alive do you think
justin bieber should i reveal that you
should reveal the truth which is the two
truths and the lies should you know
but this is your life baby i don't i
don't want to impact okay let's go one
by one okay
um
you did make out with the weekend and
you did say that he's the best kisser
ever yes or no that is correct that is
correct
shout out to the weekend bro keep doing
what you're doing with those little
tickets
making out with the lovely ladies like
nikki and get us some tickets we don't
talk no mo sorry really what happened
just you know he couldn't feel his face
when he was with you huh
what happened nikki nothing i'm not
where'd you make out with the weekend
in l.a okay in a club in a in the
backseat of a car and a dinner where
where'd it go down honestly i i can i
just be honest him and i talked and we
were like look we're not gonna talk
about this ever again in any interview
so i'm gonna keep my word um okay but we
just talked about it
okay it was a game yes okay okay but
what do you owe the weekend at this
point are you still friends with him no
so he gives a [ __ ] nah is he getting
your tickets to the concert nah
[ __ ] you gotta get because of
the concert we're telling everybody
what's going on no no he's honestly i
will say this he's one of the nicest
people ever
yeah yeah um
should we say the next truth and we'll
get into what the lie is yes yeah the
next truth is that nikki allegedly
just likes a regular-sized penis yeah
yes i do i can totally see that yeah you
could nick it's not gonna work between
us i'm sorry
okay okay whatever i'm gonna ask the
last girl you
dated got to you okay so what is it
about just being a regular old guy that
isn't uh okay
what do you say what do you mean by
regular uh what do you mean by regular i
mean i'm talking about what's your
regular stuff okay first of all do you
guys know that average size differs by
countries that makes sense
same with height same with okay exactly
so to me like i don't i'm not a size
queen i know that in porno the bigger
the dick the better you also have to
remember we use cameras that make the
dick look bigger is that the trick wide
wide angle cameras okay
but like i don't want to notice yourself
buy some wide-angle cameras for the uh
your homemade videos got it but but
exactly look when i'm dating a guy like
if you're six and a half to seven that's
perfect
i don't want anything bigger like that
[ __ ] hurts man got it all right
that's regular
can i dab you up there i know what
you're saying so so now i know what size
you are gotcha
i just found out just revealed that i
that nikki and i could qualify depends
on what country though yeah um i'm huge
for japan
huge
all right so the one lie
was kind of a half-lie because you
didn't bang justin bieber but you had
multiple friends that have and they
revealed to you that homie has his
packing oh yeah it's like those skinny
white boys
always but why
because it's like they're so skinny that
you know it's kind of like the camera
factor yeah yeah
so yeah tell us the justin bieber story
of my porn
girlfriends have banged him and they
said that he is
big hmm i don't know what that means but
because they do porn you could only
assume that they really meant it like
he's packing wow
but think about it he's hot he's
talented and he has a big dick wow
is it too late to say sorry justin i
mean you're doing your thing homie
blessed wow yeah hashtag good luck i am
yeah um so but you didn't have the good
fortune i i did not bang him now no okay
and would you say who the ladies are i
will not okay but are they are known
commodities
they um they're i think they're both
retired by okay but are they as famous
as you or even as somewhat famous as you
what is fame it's so relative okay let's
pull up her instagram
okay that's five million with a check
mark let's just say that's the barometer
for fame um oh they're a little less a
little less so about a million
i don't even know if they have an
instagram anymore
this is like this is like justin bieber
seven eight years ago probably okay and
how many years ago was this with the
biebs
um
i don't know give her two seven eight
seven is he even 21 how was it justin
bieber
he's definitely married so maybe
i don't
call us up again she's texting me all
the time i'm just like oh yeah why is
she texting you because she wants to
know the truth about who's justin's bang
and i said i'd find out
justin's 28th so he was he was he was
above age at the justice 28 or is that
crazy justin bieber 28 remember when the
kid was 12. he's pete davidson pete
davidson 28. and he's davidson is the
same age as justin bieber and he's
dating a 41 year old
who would you rather bang pete davidson
or justin bieber justin bieber yeah
i don't know but obviously pete is also
pagan yeah you think so yeah
he looks like he is look at him really i
just don't like him well he's six four i
mean you would he did six four yeah he's
tall as [ __ ] or six three yeah something
like that
interesting
i i was on a podcast and he was one of
the guests really nice guy
uh-huh nice long time ago yeah
nice guy
uh
did he try it did he try to no no no not
at all but like when you look at him i'm
like what like what color is he see gray
yellow he can be pasty white though
around the eyes
what is he you know i mean i just don't
know what he is he's awkward is what he
is he's awkward but hey you know what
i'm not going to hate ariana grande kim
k kate beckinsale he is banging a
billion dollar [ __ ] bro good for him
that's why this is a money show ladies
and gentlemen at the end of the day it
comes down to the billion dollar [ __ ]
yeah so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]